ми маємо зняти кошти з чиновників і
передати їх тим хто їх реально потребує
На жаль таких категорій є дуже багато ну
я наведу один приклад Давайте скажемо
чесно яка одна з найголовніших проблем
які сьогодні є в Україні наш самий
цінний ресурс це є люди І в нас
колосальна демографічна проблема Ну
колосальна війна виїзд мільйонів
українських жінок та дітей Ну це це
колосальна проблема А як ми вирішуємо цю
проблему в тому числі дивлячись вперед а
ми платимо сьогодні мамі на дитину 860
грн на місяць на маленьку дитину чи
можна на 860 грн утримувати дитину Ну
мені здається відповідь очевидна Так
давайте заберемо гроші в чиновників і
віддамо дітям бо якщо ми хочемо щоб цих
дітей було більше щоб ми не сиділи в
пустій країні через 10-20 років